first of all congratulations on the film
i know that this was a long-term passion
project of yours so i would imagine that
you were careful in your decision to
make your first viking movie what was it
about robert edgar's that you knew he'd
be the perfect partner
we met about
five six years ago and i just seen his
first feature the the witch it was a
combination of that having seen that and
i was incredibly impressed by
the world he was able to create on a
very limited budget how rich and
immersive it felt and uh
how authentic everything felt
and robert's um
passion for norse mythology when we met
he had just gotten back from iceland and
uh had just like myself fought and
fallen in love with the the culture and
the people and uh again that was kind of
the the starting point for what
ultimately became the northmen we teamed
up with the ambition of trying to make a
big
epic viking adventure but based it on
the old icelandic sagas so
something that felt historically
accurate and would capture the esses of
those old sagas the the the harsh
climate nature the harsh people and um
in the very laconic dry language uh to
kind of to try to capture that was was
the goal yeah and another thing that you
guys sort of brilliantly captured i
think is the brutality of that time
period both between what the world gave
folks at that time and what they gave
each other i know that that made the
shoot sort of very difficult but you've
done like a lot of i would say
challenging shoots how did this one
compare to like you know what you have
to do for say like tarzan or some of the
other stuff you couldn't cheat anything
and
cheating is quite lovely when you make
movies because
on on most
other big action movies you got plenty
of coverage plenty of cameras going
simultaneously and you can divide it up
into smaller sections and focus on one
part of a fight scene and then move on
to the next robert shoots with one
camera on film
um and just one long continuous shot one
take the whole thing so
you can't really chop it up into bits
and pieces you have to do the whole
thing and uh meticulously plan it
because one detail isn't perfect you
have to go back to the very beginning
and start the raid or the big fight
again from from from the beginning so uh
the key to to making that work was to
really really plan it meticulously and
to months before the shoot work with the
stunt team and the the camera team and
figure out the choreography of it how we
would move and the camera's moving
simultaneously so we had to find that
relationship and make sure that worked
throughout the whole sequence and that
was um
challenging but but also exciting
because again it's it's a way i was very
unfamiliar of working like this so i i
tried to embrace it and really see it
take take that on uh head first and uh
and and if it any anytime felt
frustrating uh what kept me going was
the idea that hopefully when people
watch this it will feel immersive and
you'll really feel like you're in there
with the characters and uh that it's not
chopped up into like a a music video
with with a zillion cuts like you're
you're just staying there where the
characters throughout this in the midst
of this chaos
so that that's kind of what got me
through those those days and nights well
mission accomplished i just went and say
that because
robert i very much felt like i was in
like my valhalla
uh video game that i played for south
korea like very much that oh thank you
that your reference is very much that
and then like also i think a deep
commitment to the authenticity so i know
robert talks about being the filmmakers
who's always learning from his last
project and it seems like maybe you
learned a new style with the way maybe
he shoots but then he said that you were
like the oracle for viking culture so
talk a little bit about sort of yeah
your lifelong passion
about immersing yourself in the history
of this culture the very ambitious idea
i don't know if it was hubris but i'd
never seen a big epic viking movie that
felt historically accurate and that took
the time it's time and the people of its
time seriously and uh
and i don't criticize projects that take
a tremendous amount of creative freedom
i think that's wonderful and i think art
is all about borrowing and stealing and
reinterpreting um history and uh maybe
there is a desire to to see something
where the creative amount of freedom is
very limited where it does really feel
like you're
um not watching some something through
the eyes of our current moment but
rather you're being transported back in
time in in and to really try to capture
the essence of
what life was like
up in the in the cold north uh a
thousand years ago so again that was the
very ambitious
um
goal i don't know if we succeeded but
going into it that's kind of what we we
set out to do and then again i can't
imagine a better filmmaker for that type
of movie than robert eggs because again
he is all about authenticity and and
historical accuracy and really taking
the audience on a journey back in time
yeah i was just going to say he's been
that way since his first film yeah you
brought a little bit of that film that
what connected you together to this one
by bringing back annual taylor joy and i
think folks have already seen it just
from the previews obviously both of you
guys's resume coming into this speaks
volumes but what was it like working
together
and knowing that how much of a
two-hander this really is it is the
northmen but as folks watch the film she
is just as integral in that yeah anya is
obviously an
incredible actor but also uh
pure joy to be around and such a team
player and um
always there there were some big action
set pieces where
um anya was in
was just basically deep in the
background where she wasn't
in the midst of the fighting and we
would shoot in very remote locations um
and it was cold and wet and uh she was
she's an incredible team player and
always there pushing to make it as good
as possible uh our relationship in the
movie we talked a lot about in prep uh
there's not a lot of screen time in the
beginning like the first
part of the movie between amleth and
olga but like you said her character is
such an integral part to the story and
then
eventually it becomes you know they they
um you see that on screen as well but it
was important to
to early on even though they don't have
that many scenes at the beginning
together to really feel that this is his
fate this is destiny and that they are
connected together so we worked a lot
and talked a lot about in trying to
figure out a way to shape those scenes
so that it feels electric when when
they're on together they need each other
on that journey so that that was
important to try to capture save your
mother
thanks again uh for this film honestly i
got to see it a bit early and it's
incredible it also reunites you with
anya taylor joy so i just have to ask
you what was it like coming back to this
one from your first film to now i feel
so much has happened but then coming
back to a story with her in it i mean
it's a pleasure to work with anya she's
such a fantastic actress and like
generous collaborator
uh also you know it's you know we've
both uh improved since we worked
together uh you know and
i could go on all day about her
performance and her skill but it's all
the other thing is she's so professional
i guess like who cares but you know
she's playing this enslaved woman she's
barefoot like wearing a potato sack and
she's like conducting herself and what
and and becomes someone who is uh you
know like
an inspiration for all of the background
characters who are you know in the same
position and and excited to be there
it's a good thing to have it's a really
good thing to have on set i mean that's
so great it's like that whole you know
number one on number two on the call
sheet mentality it does set the tone
i do have to say i hope you weren't
setting the tone of shading the witch on
set because i feel like as a huge fan of
that movie i may need to defend it to
you because you've been so harsh about
it
how is that different like just your
opinion of the film because you know we
still love it let me tell you i am glad
that people like it because i'm here
it changed my entire life i'm super
proud
of the movie
knowing all the challenges that i went
through in my experience level like i'm
proud of it but i just
like you can understand
that like at it was my first movie i
don't have like i mean i still i'm
learning you know i'm still learning
thank goodness like on how to make films
like i'm i'm still learning my craft
thank goodness but like i just couldn't
get what i wanted on screen that was
what i couldn't get my imagination on
screen that's it you know so like so
that's frustrating and it's good it's a
good thing because that because it could
because that makes me like reach and
work harder on the next one you know if
i was fulfilled like i should just
retire
oh yeah don't do that don't do that
you're also three for three on your
certified fresh and we want to keep your
well close to be certified fresh so we
want to keep your street going you and
uh ryan coogler are like uh on a similar
path as far as uh out of the gate
success uh one thing i think folks are
gonna be so surprised with this one is
the action in it and i just have to talk
about the berserker scene i feel like it
was my game vikings valhalla
like come to life and like we could
really just see him as like a playable
character talk about setting up that day
and it took 30 takes is that correct i
don't know but it took four days uh and
um and it was i mean look it was really
challenging but um
but
the thing is
like there were some kind of simpler
days that in some ways were harder
because
because this we there was so much
planning that went into this so like all
of our teas were crossed and our eyes
were dotted because we knew it was the
hardest thing to do look with uh all
like all like hundreds of extras and
like all these stuntmen and horses and
cows and chickens and pigs and kids and
arrows and axes and mud mud mud mud mud
you know it was it was uh
it was difficult but it was also fun but
you know but then you get like addicted
to like white knuckling the monitor with
all these long takes i mean you know
like everyone wants to talk about the
berserker raid but like
nearly every thing is one long take you
know the
the berger raid is two shots but the
underground warrior like the mound
dweller the undead
guy fight like that's two shots as well
you know what i mean it so it's uh it
was a hard movie to make i mean you
tortured yourself on every chance you
got i mean i i get it i'm noticing a
trend here sir you don't make it easy on
yourself uh yeah it's not it's nothing
nothing
there's very few things that are easy
that are worth it
very well said i mean it goes back to
like even the lighthouse like the the
period imagery that you use to sort of
bring into the film i know that
authenticity was huge as far as this
film and obviously having one of the
most identifiable icelandic families at
the center of it and so many people from
iceland and that sort of nordic area
involved in it
talk about alex and just the commitment
to authenticity that i think both of you
put at the front of your mind with this
project
well unlike me uh alex has been
interested in vikings his whole life and
and he you know
like this this viking movie was just uh
born from extreme passion from alex and
and he demanded absolute
perfection in his performance you know
and uh and then and and and he delivered
it frankly uh but we also had the the
great pleasure of working with the
finest historians and archaeologists in
the field to to make like this you know
historically accurate viking movie which
was
frankly cool and fun
i love that and honestly yeah cool is
the best way to put it like again the
video game is the compliment it just
feels like something that you want to
get involved in and something that you
literally would love to see play out
because it's that it feels that real and
that like visceral uh i'm also though
noticing a bit of a trend with your
films too about this like uh cultism and
religions and sort of mysticism and all
of these sort of like the things that
people
find uh solace in and then like all of
that is wrapped up in a lot of birds
so
i'm just curious is that like an area
you've always been drawn to and there is
there other areas of that that are
similar to that that you want to take on
like i don't know santeria something
something else along those lines voodoo
you never know
the answer
simply is like yeah
but but also i mean you mentioned voodoo
like it was interesting because we're we
have like these berserker warriors
transforming their minds into sort of
werewolves and wherebears on the on the
battlefield and
you know
me and the experts interpreted decided
to interpret this as like a shamanic war
dance that would get us there and we
have like a few images in archaeology of
what we think are germanic spear dances
from slightly before the viking age so
then we're looking at things like
voodoo trance and like shamanic stuff
from asia and like african war dances
and polynesian war dances and uh and and
japanese bhuto and how do we like use
all these things with these like few
images
that
we think are spear dances to then try to
like you know articulate that
and say like this is how they got there
uh yeah i don't know
you